In 2009, The New Teacher Project sparked
a wave of reform when it reported that less
than 1% of teachers were rated
unsatisfactory even in school systems
with abysmal student outcomes. Urged
on by Washington, more than 30 states
adopted new teacher evaluation systems.
Good idea, but a case study in how
well-intentioned reforms can turn into
clumsy mandates. Principals in Nevada, for
example, now estimate they spend 150
hours – or 19 work days a year – filling out
required paperwork that simply
rehashes what they'd already observed in
classrooms, recorded on paper, and
discussed with teachers. It wastes time,
and that's a recipe for chasing away the
kind of great school leaders we need. And
for all of the paper shuffling, still
just one-to-two percent of teachers are
rated unsatisfactory. Look, teachers
absolutely need to be evaluated more
rigorously. The way to do this, though, is
not by imposing paper burdens. It's by
giving school leaders more authority,
leeway, and autonomy, and then holding
them responsible for what they do with
it. how do you think we should hold
How do you think we should hold educators accountable?
Let us know in your comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.